TONY?
>> ALL RIGHT.
I'LL TAKE A LOOK AT THE
COMMERCIAL BREAK.
THANK YOU SO MUCH.
APPRECIATE IT.
>>> BORDER PATROL AGENTS ARE
SEEING WHAT THEY CALL AN
INCREASE IN M MIGRANTS CROSSING
INTO ARIZONA.
NEARLY 90% HAVE BEEN SENT BACK,
BUT THE REST ARE BEING ALLOWED
TO MAKE THEIR CASE FOR ASYLUM IN
THE U.S. STARTING THEM ON A NEW
JOURNEY.
YESTERDAY WE REPORTED ON A SMALL
TOWN WHERE MANY ASYLUM-SEEKING
FAMILIES HAVE BEEN SENT, AND
LILIA LUCIANO SHOWED US PEOPLE
WORKING TO MOVE MIGRANTS TO
SHELTERS IN BIGGER CITIES.
THIS MORNING, SHE'S IN TUCSON
WHICH IS THE NEXT STEP IN THEIR
JOURNEY.
>>> YES, YES --
>> Reporter: THIS COUPLE HAVE
BEEN MARRIED FOR 35 YEARS AND
ARE FINALLY REUNITED NEARLY TWO
WEEKS AFTER THEY ENTERED THE
COUNTRY.
[ SPEAKING FOREIGN LANGUAGE ]
YOU WERE HOPING THAT YOU WOULD
GET ASYLUM, BUT YOU DIDN'T
EXPECT THAT THEY WERE GOING TO
SEPARATE YOU.
[ SPEAKING FOREIGN LANGUAGE ]
THE COUPLE FROM CUBA PLANS TO
MEET FAMILY IN ORLANDO BUT IS
CURRENTLY STAYING AT THE
NONPROFIT SHELTER IN TUCSON.
FEDERAL SPACE TO HOLD ASYLUM
SEEKERS IS LIMITED HERE BECAUSE
OF COVID AND LEGAL REQUIREMENTS.
ACCOMPANIED MINORS ARE THE
PRIORITY, AND OTHERS SEEKING
ASYLUM ARE GIVEN NOTICES TO
APPEAR AND THEN RELEASED.
FOR MANY THE NEXT STEP IS A
SHELTER LIKE THIS ONE.
>> VOLUNTEERS ARE ORGANIZING
HYGIENE KITS FOR EVERYBODY --
>> Reporter: THE PROGRAM MANAGER
SAYS THE ORGANIZATION'S ROLE
PROVIDING ESSENTIALS AND HELPING
THEM CONNECT WITH FAMILY HAS
BECOME EVEN MORE IMPORTANT.
>> ASYLUM WILL ALWAYS BE A NEED,
AND THERE SHOULD BE SOME LEVEL
OF FUNDING FROM THE GOVERNMENT
TO SUPPORT THIS WORK.
>> Reporter: THE BORDER PATROL
CL
DEPUTY CHIEF SAID 45% INCREASE
FOR ACCOMPANIED MINORS.
HE'S WORRIED ABOUT THE SUMMER
MONTHS AHEAD.
>> THE SMUGGLERS TELL THEM IT
COULD BE A ONE HOUR OR TWO-HOUR
WALK AND A GALLON OF WATER WILL
BE SUFFICIENT.
THE WALKS CAN BE DAYS LONG.
THEY'RE BEING MISLED, LED OUT
INTO THE DESERT.
>> Reporter: THIS MOTHER TWO OF
FROM VENEZUELA DOESN'T WANT HER
FACE SHOWN.
SHE CROSSED THE BORDER 12 DAYS
AGO.
HER 19-YEAR-OLD SON IS STILL IN
CUSTODY.
[ SPEAKING FOREIGN LANGUAGE ]
THE PEOPLE WHO WERE PROCESSING
YOU, THEY DIDN'T EVEN KNOW WHERE
YOUR SON WAS?
>> NO.
>> Reporter: WHAT'S YOUR BIGGEST
FEAR?
WHAT ARE YOU WORRIED ABOUT?
>> JUST HIM BEING A LONG TIME
THERE.
HE'S AN ANXIOUS PERSON, SO HE'S
ALWAYS THINKING ABOUT WHAT COULD
HAPPEN IF HE GETS BACK TO
VENEZUELA, IF HE DOESN'T SEE US
AGAIN.
>> Reporter: THEY'RE SENDING
SUPPLIES NOT ONLY TO SHELTERS
ACROSS THE STATES BUT ALSO
ACROSS THE BORDER.
NOW BORDER PATROL HERE SAY
THEY'RE EXPLORING THE IDEA OF
OPENING SHELTERS THAT ARE
ACTUALLY LEGALLY VIABLE TO KEEP
FAMILIES WHO ARE SEEKING ASYLUM.
GAYLE?
>> ALL RIGHT.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
THAT SCENE WITH THE HUSBAND AND
THE WIFE REUNITING WAS -- THAT'S
WHY THEY'RE COMING HERE.
THEY'RE COMING HERE BECAUSE
THEY'RE DESPERATE.
THEY ARE DESPERATE.
WE CAN'T LOSE SIGHT OF THAT.
A VERY COMPLICATED ISSUE.
I UNDERSTAND THAT, TOO.
>> LOVE IS LOVE AND FAMILY IS
FAMILY ON BOTH SIDES OF THE
BORDER.
>> THAT'S RIGHT.
>> PEOPLE CROSSING THAT DESERT,
SO MANY DIE.
THEY ACTUALLY HAVE PHONE BOOTHS
SET UP THROUGH THE DESERT IN
ARIZONA, I DID A STORY ON IT,
WHERE PEOPLE CAN CALL FOR HELP,
AND CPB COMES BY HELICOPTER TO
PICK THEM UP IN THE DESERT AND
PUT THEM IN -- NEAR THE U.S.